bonjour et merci de m'avoir invité à
tout l'équipe ii x2 lyon et je posais
une question si quelqu'un me va bien
qu'est ce que j'ai dans la main voyez ce
que c'est que ça vous connaissez vous
reconnaissez cet objet qu'est ce que
c'est c'est une s'affaire à mettre le et
pourquoi j'arrive pas à montrer mon
téléphone dans cet étui avec une seule
réponse peu importe
pour quelle raison je n'arrive pas à
mettre cet éléphant voilà pourquoi une
petite idée là la plus simple qui vous
vient à la tête
voilà je veux dire non je veux dire
vraiment vraiment la seule responsable
et qu'elle ne rentre pas là c'est que
cet objet c'est moi qui le crée je les
ai inventées dans l'année 2000 je vous
jure que c'est vrai l'histoire voulu
voler mais c'est vrai cet objet qu'il
est porté aujourd'hui par des centaines
de milliers de personnes je vous assure
que c'est vrai
l'année 2000 gt d'un appétit de mission
à bordeaux saint médard en jalles
j'avais mis mon atelier dans la dernière
chambre qui me restait libre et
franchement j'avais tout mon temps libre
pour réfléchir et j'ai me suis dit et je
vous jure que c'est vrai mon fils il est
là j'ai créé cet objet c'est pour ça
qu'elle est couleur et la taille ça ne
correspond pas ça correspond exactement
au téléphone que j'avais à cette époque
qu'est ce qui m'est arrivé j'ai eu
j'ai eu l'intelligence pour l'inventer
j'ai eu la capacité pour l'ocré mais
manque quelque chose
il me manquait les stratégies un peu
d'argent aussi c'est vrai alors je te
voir un monsieur d'orange de décrocher
un rendez vous à paris je les lis
écoutez monsieur qu'est ce que je peux
faire avec ça il me dit garder le bien
parce que si un chinois et le voit vous
serrez copié dans la minute qui suit et
quand je préparais cette conférence j'ai
fouillé dame est dans la maison j'ai dit
qu'est ce que je peux amener peut
commencer cette conférence alors décidé
de vous amener ça j'ai inventé ça vous
pouvez me croire que c'est motivé et je
n'ai pas gagné en rond et j'ai même pas
vendu 1 dans ma vie parce que quand je
le crée c'était trop cher et aujourd'hui
bon tout le monde n 1 et ça coûte un
nouveau 2 seront donc aujourd'hui on est
là pour parler d'excellence voilà je
comment cette histoire vous présentez un
peu mon travail l'excellence c'est tout
chaud ce qui tourne nous voulions avoir
dans la vie ça nous oblige à être à
succéder à être dans l'excès sion d'être
capable d'être meilleur dans chacun de
nos actes
évidemment c'est pas la chose la plus
simple c'est un nom facile à dire mais
un monde très compliquée à mettre en
place
c'est dépassé
d'une manière positive c'est déjà dans
chacun de nos actes de notre vie nous
avions réfléchir à chaque instant qu est
ce que je peux faire pour devenir
meilleur quand nous commençons notre vie
on pense avoir un talon on ne pense
avoir un humain dont et on essaye de
l'exprimer et c'est à ces moments là
qu'on se dit bon les premières pas pour
démarrer sa recherche c'est à dire
qu'est ce que c'est ce que je veux faire
qu'est ce que je veux devenir moi-même
qu'elle est vraiment vraiment ce que je
porte dans mon intérieur et si on
n'arrive pas à savoir qu'est-ce qui en
poste à l'intérieur au moins être sûr de
ce qu'il n'a pas envie de faire
allez-vous commencé à barrer des choses
toutes les vous ne voulez pas faire donc
et vous travaillez sur les choses qui
vous reste à faire
donc c'est dépassé c'est dé façon
excessive tout va devenir un excellente
et sportif
bon il faut s'aider dans la gymnastique
il faut et avoir une hygiène de vie il
faut avoir une régime et il faut
s'entraîner tous les jours tu veux
devenir un excellent de chefs dont il
faut exceller la quantité des plats qui
va cuisiner dans la recherche de
nouveaux produits dans la façon de fait
la cuisine dans d autres pays à prendre
pour devenir un chef d'excellence je
pensais me plaît
le presque presque ici nous sommes
devant une de nos premières et moi en
premier pendant une partie de ma vie je
te les presque presque fait jeu presque
réussi j'ai presque y arriver alors
faire j'ai presque séduit cette fille
j'ai presque eu mon diplôme j'ai presque
eu cet appartement que je voulais mais
le presque presque séjour qu'ils
s'habituent au quotidien as juste avoir
une excuse pour expliquer pour nous
expliquer et s'expliquer soi même pour
quelles raisons ils sont pas réussi
c'est à dire nous notre objectif n'a
l'excellence c'est se dépasser soi-même
arriver à faire tout le nécessaire pour
que cette presque ça devienne oui j'ai
réussi à le faire et c'est à ces moments
là qu'on commence à prendre le plaisir
de vraiment des sentir la sensation que
ce n'est plus les presque presque parce
qu' être presque puisque c'est resté au
milieu et cannes on s'habitue à rester
au milieu après on a énormément de mal à
se surpasser
si tu veux obtenir un résultat différent
ne répète pas les mêmes sanctions ça
paraît tellement évident mais nous nous
le faisons tous les jours on sait que
nous avons emprunté les mêmes chemins on
sait qu'il n'a fait les mêmes gestes
définitivement on va obtenir les mêmes
choses les mêmes résultats
il ya une seule chose qui peut nous
apprendre un échec
c'est justement à comprendre qu'est-ce
qui nous venons de faire nous ne devons
pas de faire encore une fois thomas
salva et 10 sont hélas fils il a fait
5000 essais avant de trouver la bonne
les bons films ans pour qu'elle
aboutisse allume cinquième essai qui
aurait arrêté aux 4000 4520 peut-être
aujourd'hui on serait la bougie cet
homme là il a eu la france les coureurs
l'excellence de ses dires jv régime il a
tout essayé mais qu'est ce qui les a
pris c'est 5000 échec que ces cinq mille
choses qu'il avait fait il ne devait
plus le faire voyez comme quoi on n'est
pas né avec la science exacte on est né
avec énormément de buts et plus on
apprend plus on a des doutes et plus on
redoute plus on apprend en plus nous
sommes obligés d'aller à la recherche de
cette réponse vous fois quelle réponse
les cycles il commence à se répéter
donc on finit jamais dans l'excellence
l'excellence c'est aller chercher tous
les réponses à toutes nos questions une
fois qu'on a les réponses on renouvelle
les questions à prendre oui mais à
prendre mais qui ici c'est très
important parce qu' on s'est dit bon
baisers qui je vais apprendre pour
savoir de qui je dois apprendre la
première des choses c'est savoir qu'est
ce que je vais faire je vais apprendre
d'en devenir les sprints en somme être
au monde mais j'ai vu aller chercher un
symbole c'est lui le numéro un au monde
c'est lui l'exemple mende
c'est lui le recordman mondial alors
c'est lui que je dois à qui je dois
m'accrocher c'est lui mon étoile je dois
apprendre sa carrière voir ce qu'est ce
qu'ils mangent
je vois tous les exercices qui fait ici
je peux hélas je vous donne un bon
conseil faire tout le nécessaire pour le
rencontrer et le regarder dans les yeux
et se dire you sign dis moi s'il te
plaît si toupin explique moi comme tout
fait pour courir si vite
et là vous allez obtenir une vraie
réponse et ne pas rester chez vous à
dire un jour du j'aurais dû aller
presque presque une habitude à monsieur
le préfet il a passé des mois
et puis on a laissé passer un
journaliste lui demanda un stand qu'il
l'amélioré en main pour combattre la
bombe atomique
est ce lui répond la paix là nous sommes
de ce que j'appelle l'évidence la vie
dans ce délai vie danse c'est à dire tu
arrêter les fumées mais arrête de fumer
ça paraît évident mais personne en phase
avancée mais des patchs on s'aimait des
disquettes on fait plein de charme à la
fin on fait rien c'est à dire on
continue à fumer on achète les paquets
cigares et continuent à fumer tu veux
maigrir au lieu d'être ce que je vais
arrêter les manger parce que je continue
à moi je vais continuer à grossir non on
sait mais les machines en tremblant fait
dans le parc pas eu tous les trucs est
finalement qu'est ce qu'on a mais on
continue gros comme avant bien une fille
lydia sa copine écoute je fais un régime
et pendant un mois et dit combien tu as
perdu 30 jours iv
parce que ça ne sert à rien s'il n'a pas
la volonté nous serons les instants que
nous aurions mérité bajeux j'utilise
aller en cinq essais à l'honneur
aujourd'hui c'est à dire chacun de nos
gestes ce que nous sommes aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui nous sommes pourquoi je
suis là parce que je me suis préparée je
me suis organisé c'est ce que j'ai fait
hier j est arrivé hier soir
pas sûr d'être là parce que je me dis
bon ça peut toujours arriver quelque
chose j'avais tellement envie d'être ici
devant vous que celle du japon un avion
la veille
j'ai dormi sur place je suis passé un
super soirée et aujourd'hui ils étaient
là pourquoi parce que je suis
aujourd'hui c'est ce que je tout ce que
je fais mais ce années précédentes
tout ce que j'ai vécu chacun démange
estimé amené à venir
aujourd'hui ici à être avec vous et je
suis aujourd'hui l'architecte de mon
futur sa vie à partir de ce moment là
tout ce que je veux faire c'est ce que
je veux être dans 5 10 danton je suis
les responsables et les messages faut
arrêter de penser qu'elle est monde et
changer la politique échanges que les
gouvernements échanges qui émanait riche
en jeux ça c'est sûr qu'il va pas
changer je vous laisse assurez la elle
est bien installé dans sa chaise ne va
pas s'embêter
donc commençons pour changer nous mêmes
c'est faire confiance provoquer la
chance pour que la chance et la séduire
les mais une fois qu'ils ont de la
chance ils passaient devant vous s'il
vous plaît attrapez la très fort parce
que la chance quand ça passe et si ce
n'est pas prêt il s'échappe
on lave abbas et on essaye de la ccir
essayez pas c'est trop tard les gars
qu'il était très beau défi et vous
supplie il voulait vous inviter dans ses
voisins non mais voilà les parties
et après c'est trop tard et l'autre il a
pris le thé plus mignonne et plus fins
du cioff et la nuit les futurs rentrez
chez vous à saper avec votre copine et
j'aurais pu le lire oui mais vous l'avez
pas dit oui
il a passé se préparer avant l'action
évidemment se préparer avec un fiancé
élémentaire si on se prépare pas comment
on va devenir quelqu'un de bon si quand
les choses sont là on n'est pas prêt 1
une fois un ami m'a dit écoute je t'ai
invités à côté de moi j'avais miss
univers ce mais je n'étais pas préparée
avec ma femme à côté je suis quand même
il faut se préparer sérieusement et se
faire confiance à soi même je vais
raconter une anecdote de quartier jamais
capté la passe est une histoire
personnelle
une fois j'étais à la pyramide du louvre
et je me promenais j'ai regardé un peu
la galerie du louvre à paris j'avais
changé j'étais directeur demain si je
voulais un nouveau poste et je reçois un
coup de fil j'avais envoyé plan de cv
partout et c'est la maison cartier qui
m'appellent monsieur m'a dit écoute
monsieur c'est le dernier jour demain
c'est notre dernière jours et je viens
de voir votre candidature et monsieur
suis à genève
j'étais saoul à paris et c'était le
lendemain jeudi ne vous inquiétez pas
monsieur demain je suis là alors j'ai
remonté chez moi aussi sur l'après midi
j'ai laissé mes affaires je prie le
dernier un train gare de lyon pour aller
à gênés même celui-ci arrivé à genève le
soir je vais passer ma chance dans
l'hôtel et au lieu d'aller me coucher je
l'appelle et un taxi qui m'amenait de
l'hôtel à l'endroit où j'avais mon
rendez vous
vous savez pourquoi pour n'est pas le
louper pour être sûr que c'était ma
chance parce que je devais être là à ce
moment là si les taxis mais je ne sais
pas où j'arrive dix minutes art et art
et le mec qui met dit attendez je vais
lui donner un poste un responsable
quartier s'ils arrivent même pas à
l'heure donc j'étais moins - m'a garanti
l'action s'est préparé pour l'action là
je me suis pas paraître j'ai eu les
postes je vous assure je vais pas rester
après parce que je n'avais pas elle
semblait pas plus mon poste mais j'ai vu
mon poste sa masse est allé j'ai obtenu
ce que je voulais c'est important c'est
s'est habitué à gagner un père il est
dit à son fils mais mon petit
aujourd'hui je vais t'apprendre à perdre
il est non papa tu as rien compris je
veux qu'il m'apprenne à gagner
à perdre je suis à perdre tout seul 1
les grands esprits ont toujours
rencontré une exposition de farouches
l'estimé des autres la c1 petite
anecdote je vais faire court c'est là
l'histoire de la grenouille la luciole
il ya un regret nuit yann lucioles lance
une nuit étoilée sur un lac
disons le pérou leite dit kakà est là
les crapauds issia nuit il à lui seul
est pas évolué par dévoluy est par sa
langue et la trappe est là mais il
commence à l'écraser elle a douché les
vies mais crapaud qu'est ce que j'ai
fait je t'ai rien fait pourquoi tu mets
crav pas ce qui est tout brille par qui
et où brille vous avez compris ce que je
suis en train de venir
ça va vous arriver dans votre vie
d'avoir des jaloux de votre réussite si
vous cette excellente vous savez la
capacité de réussir vous obtenez tout ce
que vous voulez il va toujours un
crapaud qui va vraiment me se rattraper
ils vouent ses crasses et donc les
premières réussir 12e est excellente et
3e savoir contourner les crapauds je
vous assure
ils sont partout vous connaissez bien
finir avec une phrase c'est un message
personnel
rappelez vous que la réussite est
l'excellence pas ça aussi pour être
conscient de monde dans lesquels nous
habitons être excellentes nous oblige à
respecter notre environnement protéger
la nature
soutenez le développement durable
respectez votre entourage humain
respectez votre famille respectez vos
amis
apprenez à vivre en harmonie en
équilibre avec votre monde notre monde
ces demandes
plus vous savez de la connaissance
plus vous aurez appris dans cette vie
plus haute c'est à votre réussite
souvenez vous que votre devoir c'est
celui des partages et d'être généreux de
faire profiter au maximum des centres de
votre succès
le secret réside dans le fait de donner
toujours donné d'être capable d'aimer et
d'être capable elle sait faire et merci
beaucoup et bonne journée